it happened folks was talking with my
mom today and she saw my review
of requiem for a dream and she concluded
that she just has to watch the movie now
because she saw my review
i broke my mom's soul for your
entertainment
but we have a new episode right that
sounds like christopher walken
but we have a new episode of wanda
vision this episode gave me at the end
what i was
really wanting in the last viewing
experience of one division i'll get i'll
get to it well first of all spoilers for
this episode of one division
not gonna be a play by play not gonna be
a total walk through but you know
spoilerish nonetheless
but this episode of wand division with
that glimpse we got at the end we have
the sitcom gimmick of one division and
then the what's really going on
in one division which has always been
there i'm just saying i'm glad we have a
glimpse of it now so the sitcom gimmick
of juan division wanda's very pregnant
doesn't want her neighbors doesn't want
people to find out because i'd be really
perplexing someone who wasn't pregnant
yesterday to be
giving birth today and you know she
gives birth and while she's going into
labor she's breaking the pipes in her
house and everyone's pipes and their
houses are breaking and that's it she
gives birth to twins but that's not
really
what's going on in one division because
you know say i read comments people were
like die you
miss the clues and i mean i noticed some
of the clues
just because i don't mention something
doesn't mean i missed it just means i
talk really fast and i don't script my
stuff
out so here i am every episode it's
almost like i can't believe you missed
this sometimes they're right sometimes
i did say it i just forgot to talk about
it but i saw the hydra logo on the watch
totally did miss the sword logo though
whatever it's like the show knew though
because the friend was like oh your
brother got killed by ultron and wanda's
like wait what did you say
and what's that around your neck people
who missed it
in the last episode jeremy were talking
to you
obviously that's a sword logo and then
it appears that lady gets ejected
like from this realm well i mean from
that realm from that realm of reality
from that reality from that construct of
reality from that question mark reality
which does seem to be some
mental truman show bubble it shows that
apparently there's this
area in space time where this is
happening so it's neat to have something
tangible like that i
like it when a show gives me that clue
that's like hey you have the shtick you
have the gimmick by the way
here's a clue it's not an answer but
it's a clue
to let you know where it's going pilot
episode of heroes season one
isaac mendes drew on the ground that
nuclear explosion in new york and you're
like oh that's a thing
we gotta stop that i like it when a show
gives me that
clue to keep me hooked the first two
episodes of one division felt like
the first episodes of heroes season two
i was like
why am i here i'm pulling hero's
references have you guys seen that show
i forget how old it actually is season
one's so good though but it does show me
that disney apparently
knew that that would happen that's why
critics got the first three episodes
and we common folk we laymen we got the
first two cause someone at disney some
bean counter was like uh well if we give
them the first three episodes and they
see that hook
at the end kind of insinuating and
giving them clues as to where it's going
there's a 40
probability that 20 of the people will
enjoy their first viewing 30 percent
more
and they were like all right let's make
that call let's give the critics the
first three episodes but i'm glad i'm
glad we have that glimpse now i'm glad
the show isn't resting on
the whole mid-century sitcom thing which
i still don't know why that is
why that you know of all the constructs
of reality why mid-century sitcoms is it
some remnants of hydra you know because
we saw the hydra watch those sword folks
apparently they're trying to get in
there and figure out what's happening as
well
so i don't think they're behind it
honestly it's probably her who's behind
it because you know she can manipulate
realities in the comic books it's one of
her powers
i said in my last video nothing in the
movies showed that she could do that and
people brought up when she
you know gave tony stark those visions
and that was manipulating realities i
see it as different though because
that's like that's giving tony stark
it's manipulating his perception of
reality
so basically she gave him a bad salvia
trip which can be an interpretation
of manipulating reality but it's not
like this this is
literally manipulating an area of space
an
area of reality speaking of salvia i
thought i was just laughing before the
show came on because i realized that one
division
is an episode of tales from the trip
right you could see that
wanda maximoff on this episode of tales
from the trip she's all like so this is
the craziest thing that happened to me
so i took some dmt and then i was in
this
mid-century sitcom where everything was
black and white reality itself was in
the 4x3 aspect ratio which is very hard
to explain but it made sense when you
were there
it was a laugh track to everything we
did and said and then while i was
dancing with my dead boyfriend
i was instantly pregnant everything
became color and now we were in the 70s
then i realized they're coming for me
and i didn't actually take dmt it was in
fact
salvia tales from the trip that's right
youtube sensors i say this for
educational purposes as a psa
don't do salvia kids that [ __ ] will
scare you so the questions
are who's doing this probably wanda
because
you know why wouldn't it be i think
they're trying to throw people off with
the recordings of like rhonda who's
doing this to you it's like well she is
because
apparently when things don't go how she
might want
she can rewind things like she's in the
game braid
also to answer that who's doing this to
you question yeah the answer is probably
like
she's like i am because i saw my
boyfriend's brain get ripped out right
in front of me i just kind of want to
hang out with him more
it's as simple as that in which case are
the people in here
are they people or are they constructs
like vision's apparently a construct
because he doesn't actually
i mean other than the fact that he's
dead so we know vision's a construct but
it is a noticeable thing how
vision acts differently than how vision
acted in the avengers movies i mean the
contrast between
avengers vision and bumbling sitcom
husband visions is not really the same
person and the neighbor the neighbor you
know is like
trimming the verge and he was cutting
into the brick
like he was glitching out or something
like you didn't even know it like he was
an mpc in cyberpunk 2077 just like
this is normal so you know we saw that
lady get thrown
out of this reality ejected from this
world
out of the sitcom fake reality into our
world and you know she plopped and
landed there because they were like hey
she's not even from this place
she's from the outside world and she
mulled her way in but the questions i
have is if you take one of the neighbors
and throw them out will they just
disappear
will they are they from the outside
world prisoners trapped in this sitcom
reality but they don't want to be
are they constructs created for this
reality in which case if you throw them
out
will they live can they live outside
that reality or where they will they
just disappear
also will her babies disappear outside
that reality
these are questions but they're
questions i'm glad i have because i
didn't have any questions before i was
like alright sitcom shtick sitcom
gimmick there you go
so i enjoy this episode largely because
yeah that end glimpse it makes things
come together we've gotten to the
compelling clues that give us glimpses
as to what's actually happening in this
false sitcom reality and wanda's
probably going to have to come to grips
with the fact that she's gonna lose her
boyfriend again
optimism all right so one division
episode three have you seen it why did
you think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]
you